this is the No Deal nightmare the
government says it's willing to risk but
wants to avoid and it's introducing new
emergency powers to try and ease
disruption on the road to Dover Sky News
can reveal civilian traffic officers
will have the power to demand documents
from drivers for the first time those
who don't comply could face fines of up
to 300 pounds the transport secretary
told me the new powers were necessary
and proportionate I can't rule out that
there'll be some disruption in the
process to making that happen but I'm
pretty certain that we will get this in
a place where you know goods will carry
on flowing we're taking all the
necessary steps including some of these
extra powers to make sure the goods can
Carolyn Flay this is that's what people
expect a responsible government to do
under the new powers drivers will be
diverted here to man Stan airfield as
part of the operation brought
contingency plans that were rehearsed
earlier this year amid warnings of
17-mile tailbacks
that could turn the m20 into a car park
on the front line they fear their
businesses will grind to a halt this
company imports from across Europe today
they're sending Italian wardrobes to
Canary Wharf and pigment to paint
manufacturers all of our drivers a UK
driver says that's not too much problem
for us because when we start bringing in
the Czech Republic the Hungarians the
Polish we wanna explain to them what
things were and they've got me tilt and
they're still asking us what do we do
how things gonna work I'm not sure
prepare for the worst and see what
happens if traffic is backed up here for
hours or days it doesn't just matter the
hall is it matters to all of us two and
a half million lorries pass through
Dover every year that accounts for 17%
of UK trade and it includes fresh food
and essential medicines industry lawyers
fear new powers could lead to conflict
it's far more than I expected in effect
what they're doing is they're turning
Highways Agency officers into part-time
policeman which is unnecessary in my
view the government has also tendered
contracts worth 300 million pounds for
additional rail air and ferry freight
capacity earlier this year it gave a
contract to a company that didn't have
any boats can you guarantee that anyone
who wins a contract will actually have
ferries yes I can actually yes
absolutely one of the things we've done
is I think learn from that experience
the government insist new powers are
necessary to keep Dover and the country
moving legislating for a national
emergency that it hopes won't happen
Paul Kelso Sky News in Kent